hello believe nation I'm coming to you
from Hollywood California I'm here on a
personal vacation as well as
interviewing Christopher gavigan from
the honest company for my book and it's
Monday and so it's time to answer
question from somebody in my mastermind
group but this one comes from rich who
wants to know what are people's concerns
are on photography and video being in
front of the camera like solo
entrepreneurs and as clients seeking to
hire photo and video companies so I've
had a lot of experience in in video more
than photo and being in the place
Hollywood here where so much video is
done I thought what I would do is break
this down and share both what I've
learned and also how I'd like to get
better so in terms of being in front of
the camera the biggest things that I've
learned are one to be myself uh it's
hard being yourself is hard but I think
most people when they first go on
YouTube refers to how to make videos
they're try to be a perfect version they
try to be the polished version and
usually that's the person that's hardest
to connect with where when you can be
vulnerable when you can be human when
you can show you know mistakes or when
you feel like when you can be genuine
feel like the message that you're you're
speaking is coming from the heart then
it's much easier to connect with people
and you're gonna get a much better
response um the second thing I found is
it's going to inject passion and I found
the videos that I've done the best for
me the ones that moved me are the ones
where I'm more passionate than the other
ones where if I'm just talking like this
and I'm memorizing a script then it's
not so much the words you're saying but
how you're saying it the delivery is
really important and I think both of
those things have gotten better for me
terms of being human in using passion
with practice right I've done two
thousand videos on on my channel and so
that takes a lot of work and also
getting coached i'm working with janie
moon who is a media coach who helped me
a lot in getting me to be better and be
more myself so rich if you're making
these videos
I think teaching people how to be human
how to be comfortable front of the
camera how to bring their passion would
really help in terms of what I still
want to get better at I think the
biggest the biggest thing is not so much
the video and the technology it's the
message and you know there's some great
videos that are shot just off of a
iphone but the message is so powerful
that it goes viral and gets shared and
has an impact and my goal is always
impact and so my goal is I want to learn
to be a better storyteller I want to
learn to use analogies better I wanna
you know I look up to guys like Les
Brown and see how they commending
audience and how they speak and how they
bring passion everything that they do
and and I want to I want to learn from
them to not be like them but be the best
version of myself and so that's those
are the kind of resources i'm looking
for at this stage in my video career I
guess the second question was around
hiring a video production company for me
so I you know I've hired somebody I have
somebody who works for me comes
wednesdays for four hours a week to film
my videos and we usually are in and out
and about two and a half but i still
paying for the four i think the biggest
thing in terms of hiring somebody is
finding somebody who can work with you
finding someone who understands what
you're trying to do and has the skills
but then also loves what you're doing
you know and so what i do my usual
hiring process is i'll hire multiple
people on trials I make people go
through this process to see who can kind
of be filtered through and I've talked
about that a lot on the channel if you
go back you can watch my hiring videos
but for my videos they're a bunch of
people that was going to hire in one day
trials and the guy that I like the most
from his email responses I just posted
on craigslist to find my guy um the guy
like the most he he I've lined up him as
my third guy so I tried to other people
first just to get a sense of working
with them I think that's the easiest way
I didn't want to look through their
portfolio I didn't want to look at their
past videos the easiest way to work with
somebody steve is going
be a fit it's like start working
together and see if it works and so the
first two people were just okay the
first the first two people are okay they
know they use my gear um it was okay we
just didn't we didn't necessarily have
the vibe together and then the third guy
Jason came and just blew me away he
brought his own gear and you loved
everything I was doing my channel he's
you know he loves personal development
and just we clicked and that's what you
want with your your videographer so yes
you want someone to save you time and to
take that burden off of you and the
increase the quality of your videos but
more most important that I find for
anybody who hire you want somebody who
loves what you do and clicks well with
who you are in terms of what I'd still
like to develop and get better at um I
think for me it's more an issue I don't
know what I don't know you know I rely
on my team to now help me with the
videos in to create a quality product
I'm the on-camera product and they do
all the off camera stuff but it's a
great question and one I think you know
maybe getting external reviews maybe
maybe getting you rich to look at my
videos and get some suggestions that
they might be able to get better on I'm
a big believer and always having my team
and myself continue to improve and so
getting outside feedback as to how the
videos could be better i think is a good
logical next step and thank you for
making me think about that uh and i like
now to turn it over to you guys the
audience what do you think about
photography and video what are the
questions that you have what do you want
to learn riches as some contacts want to
create a series on youtube he's a he's a
photographer he's done photo shoots lady
gaga and you know big celebrities and
wants to know what kind of questions he
should be answering on his channel about
how to do things yourself as well as how
you know what to do when you're hiring
somebody to help you out so I'm curious
to know leave it in the comments below
and it also really help rich so thank
you guys for watching you need to
believe I will be on my way home
when on Thursday I believe and until
then I'm going to enjoy California so
thank you guys take care have a great
day I'll see you soon